[Musique]
vendre du rêve un autre génération
est devenu coutume
nous avons tellement d'exemples autour
de nous de jeunes personnes sur les
réseaux sociaux qui ont le fait des
millions ou qui gagnent des dizaines de
milliers d'euros par mois ou encore qui
ont monté 5 boîtes tout en sirotant des
cocktails au Bahamas
je vous rassure je ne suis pas là pour
ça
nous sommes constamment sous pression et
avant l'impression d'être en retard tout
le temps
prenons un peu de recul et de contexte
on voyageant un peu dans le passé
plusieurs milliers d'années se sont
passés entre la révolution agricole et
la révolution industrielle
un peu plus de 100 ans entre la
révolution industrielle et l'invention
de l'ampoule
un peu plus de 20 ans entre le premier
voyage de lune
elle a création d'Internet puis même pas
10 ans entre la création d'Internet et
de séquençage intégral de l'ADN
le monde progresse rapidement très
rapidement
et nous avons l'impression qu'il laisse
peu de place à la lenteur aux erreurs
tout le monde veut réussir vite et
maintenant
pourtant dans la lenteur réside les
pépites les plus précieuses dont le
temps fleurissent la maîtrise de soi la
confiance en soi
la patience et la persévérance
comment finalement peut-on provoquer sa
chance dans un monde où tout va vite
pour cela il faudrait que je vous
partage quelques leçons tirer
d'expérience vécue et nous allons
remonter dans mon passé cette fois
ou certaines situations et environnement
ont participé à façonner la personne que
je suis devenu aujourd'hui
je suis né à Casablanca au Maroc et j'ai
vécu 19 ans
je n'étais pas un élève brillant
j'étais loin d'être le futur étudiant à
domination sport ou encore le futur
ingénieur diplôme et de l'École
polytechnique et en plus de ça je
détestais le Parker
j'ai eu 6 au bac d'histoire-géographie
avec un bac à mention assez bien un doux
de moyenne ensuite je suis arrivé en
France entamer la PACES première année
comme une des études de santé l'année ou
le Parker est roi
je ne vais pas appris à être discipliné
ni habitué à travailler et encore moins
vous allez être autonome
et je me suis retrouvé à 19 ans dans un
18 mètres carrés seul et à faire face à
la jungle
certains professeurs s'amusent à nous
dire bienvenue au Hunger Games et puisse
le sort vous êtes favorable
je dispose donc un ingrédient nécessaire
pour réussir cette année
la solitude et la dépression était
les meilleures années
très rare sont les étrangers qui
réussissent leur première année de paces
on entend beaucoup parler de diversité
et j'aurais aimé croire
que le quota des étrangers allait être
plus élevés
sachez que c'est tout l'inverse
qu'on voit la chance de revenir le
week-end retrouver ses parents avoir son
réfrigérateur rempli de nourriture son
linge laver sécher retrouvez son lit
douillet et repartir revigorer
ah le bon couscous de ma mère
j'en ai rêvé je vous assure
avec le temps j'ai réalisé qu'il
n'allait pas de limite d'âge en première
année à la fac j'avais rencontré des
médecins
radio des anciens étudiants de classe
préparatoires et j'en passe et même si
l'égalité des chances n'existait pas
c'est là où j'ai appris ma première
leçon
il fallait que j'assume et que je me
responsabilise
soyons honnêtes nous fuyons tout ça
quand tout marche nous sommes les
responsables par contre quand ça ne va
pas dans notre sens c'est l'autre
ou tout
sauf nous
il y a une histoire d'inconférencier Jim
run qui somatise clairement ce concept
deux hommes se réveillent un matin et
une tempête c'était déjà installée il
pleuvait des cordes
le premier regarde par sa fenêtre et se
dit
mais quelle tempête
mais il peut face attendre à ce que je
sorte et que je fasse des ventes
et il reste chez lui le deuxième homme
le même matin regarde par sa fenêtre
voilà même tempête il se dit
waouh quel est ton pet mais tu sais avec
un temps pareil ce serait peut-être une
journée idéale de sortir faire des
ventes la plupart des gens se remportent
probablement chez eux surtout les
commerciaux
vous voyez qu'ici il existe une
différence dans la façon dont notre vie
se déroule
ce n'est pas ce qui nous arrive
c'est ce qu'on en fait
et vous
face à la dernière tempête que vous avez
vécu
et vous restez chez vous ou
avez-vous danser sous la pluie
on est tous confrontés à ce genre de
choix dans nos vies il y a différents
degrés ah j'ai environnement
généralement durant des moments pareils
deux choix s'offrent à nous
soit on se remplit de sentiments
d'injustice
on développe des émotions négatives et
on devient la pire version de nous-mêmes
ou on prend sur soi et on essaye de
trouver des solutions
trois mois et demi après la rentrée
scolaire avait lieu le premier concours
qui pesait pour plus de 50% de l'année
ça passe vite
je manquais de temps mais il fallait que
j'essaye d'augmenter mes chances de
réussite
tous les jours se ressemblait pour moi
Noël les week-ends les fêtes le nouvel
an car je passais tous ces jours là seul
et après deux ans j'ai enfin réussi à
passer en deuxième année comment
on divise par deux mes excuses et en
doublant mes actions
les années se sont enchaînés ils diront
les sept années passées à la fac j'ai vu
mes parents cette fois et le plus dur
défi durant ces années là jusqu'à ce
jour auquel nous sommes tous confrontés
c'est de rester fidèle à ces valeurs et
principes
c'est la deuxième leçon que j'ai apprise
et que j'apprends toujours
nous ne sommes pas parfaits nous devons
être prêt à se tromper
échouer redoubler d'efforts s'il le faut
mais le plus important et de garder la
tête haute
rester fidèle à soi ces valeurs et ses
principes
est-ce que ce sera facile non
il y avait-il de fortes chances que j'ai
chaud oui mais ce que j'aurais eu des
regrets si je n'avais pas au moins
essayé oui et ça c'est important à
reconnaître
j'ai normalement appris sur moi en tant
que personne
étudiant et en côtoyant des gens
complètement différents de moi car au
final la même au bouillante qui durcit
l'œuf
adoucit la pomme de terre
alors en restant fidèle à mes valeurs et
principes j'ai été certes refusé à plus
de 200 candidatures avant de décrocher
mon premier poste mais quand je l'ai eu
c'était exactement celui qui me fallait
à ce moment
car quand on reste soi-même
les gens valorisent pour qui vous êtes
pour qui vous prétendez être
changeons
quand j'étais étudiant je ressentais que
quelque chose manquait ce côté créatif
qui était très assoiffé j'aurais aimé la
sourire mais j'étais pris par les études
et à la fin du parcours universitaire je
découvre le Cours Florent j'ai mis
inscrit pour un workshop acting English
je passe l'audition qui te sous forme de
monologue duologues c'est à plusieurs et
quelques semaines après je reçois un
mail
j'ai été admis à leur programme de trois
ans en anglais
et là je panique
d'un coup je ne sais plus ce que c'est
de ce responsabiliser d'assumer je
n'arrive pas à y croire car ce côté
créatif que j'avais étouffé pendant une
éternité avec sa chance de s'exprimer
maintenant à un rythme assez intensif
mais de l'autre
il fallait que je trouve mon premier
boulot à temps plein
pour renouveler mon titre de séjour
j'avais une thèse à rédiger et à
soutenir
et ce que j'allais pouvoir gérer tout ça
j'avais provoqué ma chance mais ce que
j'allais pouvoir la saisir
c'est toute une autre problématique
imaginez-vous l'entreprise qui vous fait
rêver qu'elle soit basée aux États-Unis
ou peu importe un endroit que vous
estimez en dehors de votre portée demain
matin la boîte vous appelle
oui bonjour
est-ce qu'il y a des potentiel nous
aimerions vraiment vous voir au sein de
notre équipe si vous acceptez vous
commencez à la semaine prochaine
revenez vers nous le plus rapidement
possible car les places sont plutôt
limitées
comment allez-vous vous sentir
c'est exactement ce que j'ai ressenti
[Musique]
après avoir consulté mes parents et
quelques proches je décide de me lancer
sans savoir où j'allais atterrir
et il fallait laisser le tout garder
financer les cours gérer tout le reste
sans paniquer
et ainsi j'ai validé ma première année
au cours Florent rédiger soutenu ma
thèse avec brio
trouver gérer mon premier boulot à temps
plein mais ce n'est pas ça le plus
important le plus important je voulais
dévoiler juste avant
je n'ai pas réussi seul
ma confiance en moi a été fortement
appuyé par le soutien de mes proches
les vrais amis vous encourageant et vous
soutiendront dans vos choix et décisions
je n'aurais pas sauté le pas à mes
proches dans ma soeur rime qui m'a dit à
sa manière si tu sautes le pas maman te
fera le meilleur couscous du quartier
quand tu reviendras
je vous avoue que négociations n'ont pas
duré très longtemps
croire en moi n'a pas été facile
surtout qu'on la plupart de l'entourage
vous regarde différemment
combien de fois vous vous êtes senti
incompris ou désespéré car vous
n'obtenez pas ce pourquoi vous aviez
autant travailler
combien de fois ressenti vous que les
murs se refermer sur vous et
l'impuissance vous submergez tendeur
passez tant de préparation que ce soit
pour un projet un entretien un devoir
peu importe il ne faut pas cesser de
croire en soi nous avons besoin de nous
car depuis notre naissance jusqu'à la
fin de notre vie
on ne se quittera pas une seule seconde
et le jour où vous douterez de vous-même
vos proches seront là pour rallumer
cette flamme qui se met en vous car quoi
qu'on vous dise personne ne réussit seul
n'ayez pas peur d'échouer j'oserais même
dire
oser échouer il faut aller chercher les
chèques pour provoquer sa chance
et si ça peut en rassurer certains ou
certaines la vie est tellement risquée
que personne n'en sortira vivant
le monde dans lequel on vit progresse à
une vitesse folle en se responsabilisant
tout en restant fidèle à ses valeurs et
principes on peut réellement provoquer
sa chance la saisir par contre nous
avons besoin de nous
et de personnes qui croient en notre
potentiel même qu'on nous le réalisons
pas
je clôturé ce talk en vous invitant à
réfléchir à l'idée suivante
nous sommes tous nés nus et fragiles
nous repartirons de ce monde tout aussi
nu et fragile par contre ce que nous
avons fait
faisons et feront par la suite dépend en
grande partie de nous
à vous de jouer
[Applaudissements]